[Music]
uh I was driving here this kind of put
me in a strange mood I I'm not currently
in a relationship but sometimes I see
people I see
them sometimes I've observed these
people in relationships this is what
happened this morning I pulled up next
to another car and their windows were
down and I caught just a little snippet
you ever catch a snippet of a
relationship and you're like I've seen
all I need to
say you can totally make a judgment on
it this is what I saw the girl was just
kind of kind of going off the guy was
kind of zoning out and she was like I
just think rainbow sprinkles it's
implied that and then she's just going
on and on and he's just like I just say
it's a different kind of taste like a
plasticky kind of crunch
taste and then the guy it was he could
tell just by her Cadence slowing down
that it was his time to talk and he just
went
wellow that's
crazy that is the death rattle of any
any relationship cuz you don't mean
that's crazy what you mean is I want to
heave you into an active
volcano just end it you're throwing out
a wow that's crazy what you really mean
is we need to talk this is this is over
sprinkles but I love love let's talk
about love I love love real love real
love not yes you can clap for
love the love that makes you completely
unrelatable to the rest of your friends
you know what I'm talking about like if
you want to know if a movie was good you
can't ask your couple friends that are
in love you know what I mean you'll
never get an honest answer you're like
oh what was gravity about oh gravity was
great it was great it was about darkness
and snuggling it was about snuggling
there was a real subplot of
snuggling closeness and sneaky
kisses you know George Clooney was there
and we were in space but it was mostly
about sneaky kisses just just well time
sneaky kiss kisses if you want to know
how a movie really was you got to ask
your single angry friend you know what I
mean how was gra like it was all right
was fine it's about a lady hurling alone
through space very
relatable as he's heating up tonight's
soup but that's what I want I want crazy
love the real stuff the Romeo and Juliet
the Bonnie and Clyde Sid and Nancy he
usually doesn't end well all of those
examples are tragedies but the problem
is is like most people aren't like oh
what light in yonder window breaks is
the East and Juliet is the son that's
not most people most people are like
Claire's pretty
cool I don't want that I don't want
Claire's pretty cool I want that crazy
stuff I'm divorced but I still believe I
don't want to be that bitter guy alone
at a wedding six open bar whiskies
in rented cumber bun open to let out
that stomach that chose both the chicken
and the fish just like calling it from
the back I give it two
years that piece of
it's going to fail and where's that
mother of the bride she's got a great
tush that guy calling tushes don't get
me wrong it's a great tush it's a great
tush I would tear up that
tush nobody wants to see this face say I
would tear up that
tush but that just happened I just would
really punish the tush is that
better oh my God that's the right that's
the right response just a quiet moment
in the audience and someone goes oh my
God that's what I'm going on but back
back to true love let let's stay let's
stay on course so I just keep looking
I'm going to keep looking until I find
it I want to find the Bonnie to my Clyde
the Nancy to my Sid and you know when I
find my sweet Juliet I'm going to say it
again I'm going to straight up punish
that tush I'm going to it's a great CH
it's a great
[Music]
ch